you know I've just I'm not in there I'm
not feeling you know what they say it
goes down in the dance and on Saturday
it went down after 50 cent shared a
screenshot of his private DMS with Will
Smith who straight-up cursed him out
after the rapper shared his two cents no
pun intended on wills wife Jada Pinkett
Smith's past relationship with August
Alsina you know we're just not quitters
here's what went down 50 reached out to
will to check on him after Will and Jada
sat down for a very candid convoy on her
Facebook watch series read table talk
Friday you and I were going through a
very difficult time yeah
and we decided I was done with you yeah
you come with you yeah we basically we
broke up yeah in case you missed it Jada
admitted to getting into what she called
an entanglement with singer August
Alsina while she and will were separated
it is a little weird that all this stuff
is coming out now since this was yeah
cuz for me this was years ago now back
to 50 the rapper shared this screenshot
of his convo with actor on Instagram
Saturday after he asked will if he was
okay will responded that he was cool and
he appreciated the concern friendly
enough right next 50 asked why Jada
would quote tell you that on a show for
everyone to see and will said we broke
up so she did her and I did me then 50
reference the moment that Jada
shot down august's claims that will gave
him permission to date Jada now the only
person that could give permission in in
that particular circumstance is myself
yes 50 wrote quote then she said only
she can give permission for somebody to
blow her back out yeah I will no likey
his response was blonde
AF Cupid
the candy shop singer was clearly
confused by the four-letter mic drop
writing wait what I do I realized it's a
whole lot better when people know you
will smoke
this whole thing started in June when
August sat down for an interview with
Angela hee and claimed that those
long-standing rumors that he and Jada
were a thing weren't just rumors and I I
totally gave myself to that relationship
for years of my life you know and I
truly and really really deeply loved and
have a ton of love for her I voted
myself to it I gave myself to it
Jada confirmed the 27 year-old wasn't
lying about their relationship
addressing it all at the read table with
will by her side including their
eventual split as I came through and
started to realize certain things about
you and I he decided to break all
communication with me which was totally
understandable
right of course Will and Jada found
their way back to each other and now the
couple says they are totally committed
to each other
for better or worse 25 years and
counting mmm we ride together we die
together